our series our more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is greater than what divides us almost
50,000 workers walked off the job more
than two weeks ago at America's biggest
automaker that's General Motors it's
estimated the strike has cost GM more
than a billion dollars but one Ford auto
worker helped lessen the divide in
Detroit Kris Van Cleave shows us how he
United the rival car Giants one selfless
acts like the f-150 at every 53 seconds
roll off this line Fredo Pacheco is
built Ford Tough
there's no other vehicle better than a
Ford but what really drives this auto
worker is building more than America's
best-selling truck I mean what he saved
my life
I'm here because of this guy's fellow
auto worker Rick fully felt sick four
years ago turns out he needed a
life-saving liver transplant Rick and
his wife Carolyn knew the odds one in
five in his situation don't make it you
get really desperate I mean it's yeah
and I was dying every day until the day
he met his match somebody in my heart I
knew I knew I was his match
the Ford worker found a new focus even
though the two men had never actually
met because Rick worked way down the
line at crosstown rival General Motors I
didn't imagine that there was a human
someone out there that was going to want
to save my life I didn't think would be
a stranger after no family member was a
fit and he looked for liver donors as
far away as North Carolina Rick's wife
Carolyn who works at the same plant is
Fredo posted this desperate plea my
husband Rick Foley needs a liver
transplant
Carolyn was just a co-worker I didn't
know how much she was a high end
boyfriend at work
Rick I never met him I met on the day I
told them the day you told him the day I
told them so hi it's nice to meet you
I'm giving you my liver basically they
knew I was trying but they didn't know
it was his match it
frado's wife Cathy captured how long the
hug lasted when he shared the news
it's literally someone taking you out to
dinner let you know that they're gonna
save your life and actually this is the
date that they're gonna the surgery's
gonna happen if you're available good
right the father of five was a perfect
match but the pair faced a setback
doctors said Fredo was 28 pounds too
heavy for the surgery so he started
working out before and after his
ten-hour overnight shift and Fredo made
his goal by one pound but the surgery
still had its risks living liver
transplants are rare only a few hundred
happen in the u.s. each year and one in
500 donors don't survive the surgery
we find these living donors to be the
most inspiring individuals to have at
work with dr. Marwan Alba Zed performed
part of the successful transplant here
at Detroit's Henry Ford Hospital he is
the fullest of human potential Fredo
it's a gift I can't repay but I can
spend a lifetime being his friend and
when his friend Fredo after years of
making the f-150 for the first time
bought his own bed of sweet he knew
right where to drive it when you see a
man frail and no one he's gonna die soon
to where he is now that looks awesome
it's an amazing gift do you ever feel
the urge to remind him that it's it's
essentially a Ford part that's keeping
the Chevy going all the time we do it
all the time for CBS this morning Kris
Van Cleave Detroit he's the fullest of
human potential
especially when you think that he's a
high-end boyfriend I you know I just
wouldn't give my body part to someone I
don't know I just wouldn't do it I don't
know if that makes me a bad person but I
just
so I admire people who can just when I'm
making oh wow
you might you haven't met the right
person I think I think in the right
circumstance you might yeah okay